[Musique]
au programme danse et 7,8 sport du 21
mars du football d'abord avec le club de
l'ouest et les mureaux qui espérait
poursuivre sa bonne dynamique à la
maison face à l'équipe réserve du paris
saint-germain résultats à suivre dans ce
numéro nous reviendrons ensuite sur
l'éco trail la course de 80 km qui part
de l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines c'était ce week-end nous
suivrons entre autres le parcours de
trois frères qui ont pris le départ de
cette 15e édition enfin comme chaque
semaine une immersion dans un club
yvelinois cette fois zoom sur le club du
sky haltéro avec michael et demi d'euros
créée en 2018 le club compte aujourd'hui
une cinquantaine d'adhérents c'est parti
pour ce 7,8 sport
un dimanche de gala au stade léo
lagrange des mureaux avec un derby
yvelinois le fcm 9e de national 3
recevait l'équipe réserve du paris
saint-germain troisième on est rentré
timidement eux nous ont vraiment ils ont
vraiment acculés sur notre défense nous
aurons très bien dans ses specs ce qui
nous a réveillés et suivi d'un but donc
c'est à ce moment là on s'est réveillés
on a été plus agressif on est restés
plus à distance d'intervention par
rapport aux joueurs mauvaise entame de
match pour les rouge et bleu et un but
concédé à la 12e minute les muriautin
réagissant suite avec tout d'abord deux
grosses occasions
avant l'égalisation à la 38e minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai pas peur parce que s'ils savent
et en début de saison oui mais là je
connais l'état d'esprit de mon équipe on
est bien physiquement on est bien on est
capable de marquer à tous les matchs là
où il faut aller jouer c'est surtout
quand le psg n'avait pas le ballon là on
voyait que les trois attaquants ne
revenait pas défendre et ctc brèche là
qu'il faut l'exploiter et c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé à mes excentré de bien
animer leur couloir au retour des
vestiaires le fcm impose la même
intensité et pousse le gardien parisien
à l'erreur
[Applaudissements]
penser que c'est l'équipe a les
meilleurs avec le ballon que nous mais
nous on avait
mais nous nous n'avait on avait la dalle
on avait faim on avait faim de gagner ce
match prendre une revanche on a perdu 2
0 là bas a pris un rouge etc du coup on
avait faim on va se fait tranchant et ça
paie à un quart d'heure du terme
l'équipe fait le break 3 ça sera le
score final
relégable depuis début décembre le fc
les mureaux pointe aujourd'hui à la
huitième position et n'a plus perdu à
domicile depuis le 7 novembre c'est
surtout les de rectifier les choses
c'est une équipe à l'aller pj nous
avaient battus 2-0 là aujourd'hui on est
capable de leur en mettre 3 la semaine
prochaine on reçoit créteil qui nous en
avait quand même passé 4 aussi ccd match
alors qu on doit être capable aussi de
rétablir que ce qu'on avait fait à
l'aller c'était des accidents est
aujourd'hui bas chez eux ils nous ont
fait du mal à nous on le rend coup pour
coup même si l'objectif premier du club
reste le maintien à neuf journées de la
fin les joueurs ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille on sait que pour monter ça
va être très difficile mais finir dans
le top 5 ce serait magnifique à la
prochaine journée le fcm reste à la
maison avec la réception de l'équipe b
de l'us créteil lusitanos
on débute ce tour des résultats du
week-end par du football et versailles
qui continue son hégémonie en nationale
2 une nouvelle victoire la troisième de
rang sans encaisser de but 2 0 sur la
pelouse de granville avec la défaite de
blois foot 41 contre l'autre
pensionnaire yvelinois de la poule là et
ce poids si les versailles et compte
désormais huit points d'avancé sur leur
seul poursuivant pour la montée le c#
voici s'éloigne encore davantage de la
zone de relégation et pointent à la 10e
position en régionale 3 maintenant
laisse maurepas et la réserve de
versailles joue toujours le titre
victoire à la maison des morts pas bien
face à villeparisis ce 2 0 l'asm ne
pointe plus qu'à deux longueurs de la
première place avant d'affronter le
leader le club du gretz tournan pour la
prochaine journée
quant à versailles l'équipe était en
démonstration à l'extérieur 4-0 face aux
ulis pour conserver la troisième marche
du podium cycliste habitants et
s'entraînant dans les yvelines anthony
turgis ca réalisé la performance du week
end
deuxième place lors de la mythique
course du milan san remo dans le groupe
des favoris il se positionne devant
mathieu van der powell et à 2 secondes
derrière le slovène matej moritz
vainqueur c'est la meilleure performance
de la carrière du coureur de 27 ans dans
un monument qui s'est confié frustré
mais sans regret en sport féminin week
end ensoleillé pour l'équipe de basket
du chesnay versailles en nationale 2
avec sa victoire 47 40 contre l'un des
concurrents directs à la montée le club
de saumur l'équipe reste au contact des
deux premiers du classement à un point
seulement du leader angers il reste deux
journées à le fcv pour espérer un
faux-pas deux équipes de tête enfin on
termine par du handball et une autre
victoire les filles de montigny le
bretonneux l'ont emporté 31 23 sur
lanester lésigny montagne rebondissent
après deux défaites de suite avant
d'aller chez le premier le cercle rennes
le 2 avril prochain
bonjour aux gens
tina fey en france
il s'appelle romane oleksandr jaroslaw
ou encore consciente in ce sont des
joueurs de football ukrainien avec leur
entraîneur jury yaroshenko il est
d'arriver à poissy ils sont accueillis
ici à cause de la guerre en ukraine en
leur honneur le président du club de
football et le maire karl olive ont
organisé une cérémonie l'idée c'est
qu'ils assainissent leurs patients qui
continue à jouer et puis moi j'avais
s'ils ont une licence de moi et que dans
trois mois c'est la fin de la guerre je
serai le plus heureux des hommes on la
mettra dans l'avion on rappellera les
billets d'avion et on partira sûrement
la larme à l'oeil mais avec un gros
sourire sous ce qui me qui m'anime à moi
en tout cas la première des actions que
je mets en place maintenant c'est de
demander à l'état et à la fédération
française de football d'accorder des
licences rapidement pour que ces jeunes
ces jeunes puissent jouer il évolue en
deuxième division ukrainienne ça va nous
faire du bien
[Musique]
oui
footballeur professionnel de lipova
dolina club de deuxième division
ukrainienne ils se sont tout de suite
mis dans le bain un premier entraînement
avec les joueurs pisciacais évolue en
quatrième division
c'est une fierté parce qu'on montre
qu'on est là pour aider les gens et que
que le footsie césar c'est partage c'est
envie d'aider les autres qu'on se met à
leur place et c'est pas facile pour eux
on vit à travers les réseaux sociaux par
ce qui se passe par la télé on voit ce
qui se passe et c'est franchement pas
évident qu'après ne nous sont pas
apportées à notre manière le fait est
qu'ils puissent venir s'entraîner avec
nous et les mettre dans les meilleures
dispositions disposition les gestes
techniques sont fluides les connexions
entre les joueurs paraissent naturelles
malgré la différence de langue français
et ukrainiens se comprennent
dans le langage du football il n'y a pas
besoin de traduire cet universel
le football c'est tout dans ma vie et je
suis très content de pouvoir m'entraîner
ici à poissy en france avec l'équipe
les joueurs ont une bonne qualité de jeu
un bon niveau on voit qu'il joue au
football depuis longtemps ils ont la
qualité technique et ils sont forts et
le coach pisciacais walid haïchour
propose même à son homologue ukrainien
d'animer une séance d'entraînement ce
lundi sera beau match et c'est pas une
idée n'est joué samedi
basé sur la technique si c'est la
technique c
c'est une course au plus près de la
nature l'eco-trail 2022 s'est déroulée
ce samedi 19 mars cinq courses au total
avec différentes distances 10 18 30 45
km et l'épreuve mythique des 80 km au
départ de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'au premier
étage de la tour eiffel le vainqueur de
cette 15e édition s'appelle nicolas du
high il a couru le parcours en 5 heures
49 minutes côté femme marilyn nakache a
terminé les 80 km en 6 heures 44 minutes
au total 2500 tr l'heure était inscrit
sur cette distance
grégory canal et on a rencontré quelques
uns sur la ligne de départ mais j'ai
qu'une envie c'est de partir voilà là
j'aime bien c'est cette émotion qu'on a
avant le départ pour l'instant je me
sens bien ça va mais c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle non si je me sentais pas
bien moi aussi je sais pas conseillé
d'avoir plus tard mais pour l'instant ça
c'est mon premier coup très qu'après
stressé partie notre vie qu'on va voir
ce qui va se passer on va essayer de
finir et c'est l'essentiel 80 kg mais
j'ai jamais fait maintenant où j'avais
envie de me lancer j'ai toujours aimé la
cour donc fallait que je me lance
dernier entraînement
avant les côtes règles de paris donc de
saint quentin jusqu'au premier étage de
la tour eiffel pour 80 km
l'objectif le seul c'est déjà de le
finir
[Musique]
hâte hâte de commencer d'être sur le
parcours s'il ya quand même quelques
mois de préparation donc à de le vivre
et on a le beau temps avec nous donc
c'est chouette on a des bonnes
conditions
à moins d'une heure du départ je dirais
qu'on premières' entière en tout c'est
un peu de stress
mais pas non plus tellement à ce que
pour moi l'objectif est notamment de le
finir un peu de stress c'est sûr c'est
quand même une grosse découverte pour
nous comment on a été fortement
influencée par le grand frère après
après un raid de 60 bornes il nous a dit
je m'inscris sur 1,80 on s'est invitée
avec antoine on a fait un semis donc ce
à quoi sert il ya quand même un bon
stress quoi et j'espère vraiment qu'on
va arriver à la tour eiffel
on va courir voilà entre entre 7 et 10
heures voire cuisson c'est rien c'est
dingue quoi on va courir un petit peu
aussi pour pour soutenir si on va penser
en tout cas au petit aiden qui acquit à
22 mois qui atteint d'un cancer du
cerveau
du coup on sait voilà bah on va courir
entre autres pour ça et aussi guillaume
qui courent contre l'endométriose
toujours pour essayer d'en apprendre
toujours plus contre cette maladie
d'après les experts faut s'économiser
sur sur les montées on attaque on est
bientôt au 10e km et ronger à prendre
mon petit avion un petit peu plus vite
et puis
voilà
to
[Applaudissements]
you
km 58 coutière 52 voilà c'est dur je
découvre des muscles
c'est ça la tour eiffel
[Musique]
ni
c'est un habitué de l'exercice dans les
yvelines sidy diallo et son palmarès de
plus de 300 marathon en dix ans ont pris
le départ de l'eco trail mais dans sa
version 45 km le coureur s'est même
permis un petit détour pour un totale
parcourue de 56 km il est arrivé au pied
de la tour eiffel dans les temps en 6h10
aujourd'hui pour ce module sport nous
sommes à montillot bretonneux pour
découvrir l'haltérophilie nous sommes au
club sky haltéro
pour découvrir ce club je suis aux côtés
de serre et le président du club alors
quel est l'historique de ce club alors
ce canal terreau était créée il ya
quatre ans maintenant en 2018 l'idée du
club d'haltérophilie vraiment de donner
accès aux loisirs aux compétitions de
faire ce sport qui est pour nous un
excellent pour la santé il a été créé en
2010 8,1 c'est bien ça 2018 c'est ça oui
et du coup combien d'adhérents au total
au total on a une cinquantaine
d'adhérents en comptant les ans les
teens liquide et les adultes donc
réparti en 50 % ou quasi 50 % de
féminines lots restants masculin et
pourquoi avoir voulu créer ce club ici
alors on a depuis quelques années le
crossfit qui arrivait assez fort ou
l'haltérophilie fait partie d'une des
composantes du crossfit et donc
à l'origine le président du club l'a
créée pour renforcer cette compétence
d'haltéro pure qui sert au cros suite et
on a remarqué qu'il y avait de plus en
plus de demandes pour faire deux
latéraux en spécifique et donc l'idée
c'est le pourra faire des compétitions
d'haltérophilie pur
dans les yvelines est d'autant plus à
saint quentin en yvelines où on est le
seul club est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
clubs dans les yvelines d'haltérophilie
alors à ma connaissance non je crois pas
tous les connaître je pense qu'on est
quatre clubs dans les yvelines si je me
trompe pas et qu'est ce qui fait que ce
sport est peut-être un peu confidentiel
je pense qu'on se rapproche dans l'image
du body building qui est pas forcément
toujours bien vu par le grand public
l'haltérophilie est très éloigné de sa
vue qu'on a des bars
on se rapproche beaucoup de ces sports
bodybuilding power lifting et tout un
peu mélangés dans le grand public bien
que aux jeux olympiques on voit
l'haltérophilie qui a le seul sport avec
des barres qui est pratiqué oui
justement les jeux olympiques est ce que
ça vous aide à recruter des gens
je ne sais pas oui certainement en fait
on découvre beaucoup de gens découvrent
l'haltérophilie en regardant les jeux
olympiques et ensuite viennent essayer
mais quand je les dis beaucoup viennent
du crossfit quand même à l'origine qui a
démocratisé beaucoup ce sport et qu'est
ce que c'est concrètement
l'haltérophilie on les voit il soulève
beaucoup de poids derrière est ce que
c'est ça soulever des poids ou est-ce
que c'est plus complexe que ça alors la
base c'est soulever des poids mais après
c'est comment soulever des poids donc en
fait l'haltérophilie se décompose en
deux mouvements on à l'arraché on
dépasse la barre des mares du sol pour
être jusqu au dessus de la tête bras
tendus en un seul mouvement et on à
l'épaulé jeté ou une épaule la barre sur
les épaules puis on la met bras tendus
au-dessus de la tête donc ces deux
mouvements en compétition l'épaulé jeté
et l'a ratée qui sont importants après
dans un entraînement on va justement
face à optimiser ce mouvement-là travail
et des parties de mouvement ou la
totalité pour faire le plus de poids
possible il y a à peu près la moitié des
adhérents de votre club qui sont
compétiteurs aussi un objectif c'est
désormais en compétition effectivement
on a tous une partie loisirs
où ils vont certainement se renforcer
pour d'autres sports vous faire
l'haltéro pour le loisir par contre la
moitié compétition vont faire des
compétitions dédié à l'haltérophilie on
a un peu tous les niveaux on a des
débutants on va jusqu'en national donc
tout le monde et les bienvenus et
surtout on a un coach qui nous permet de
monter en niveau très rapidement et
efficacement on le voit depuis quatre
ans on a de plus en plus d'athlètes
compositeurs qui ont des niveaux de plus
en plus élevés l'objectif c'est de faire
peut-être de ce club l'un des meilleurs
en france en ile-de-france au monde si
possible mais d'être en tout cas de pour
l'instant vraiment l'objectif c'est de
démocratiser d'aller de plus en plus
loin au niveau de la compétition mais
voilà d'avoir de plus en plus
d'adhérents qui aiment ce sport et qui
découvrent ce sport c'est vraiment
important pour nous c'est le fait de
démocratiser l'haltérophile vous voulez
quand même remplir l'armoire à trophées
on commence bien on commence à remplir
l'armoire à trophées effectivement et
oui le but c'est de monter le plus le
plus haut possible dans les compétitions
et on le remarque derrière derrière moi
aussi ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
ya des filles et des garçons ont
l'habitude de dire que l'haltérophilie
c'est un sport de garçons finalement pas
du tout ici alors pas du tout ici on est
on est à peu près un tiers 2 féminine
voire un peu plus c'est un sport qui est
qui est très adapté à toutes les
morphologies et puisque ça demande
beaucoup de coordination de souplesse
alors on remarque souvent les féminines
ont ce cette capacité à avoir de la
mobilité de la souplesse par rapport à
d'autres masculin quand il commence en
tout cas et donc c'est un sport qui qui
adapté à tous donc les films on aime
beaucoup ce sport là pour pour ses
aspects souplesse mobilité explosivité
et forcément
[Applaudissements]
je suis donc maintenant aux côtés de
patrice le coach de la structure alors
patrice est ce que vous avez les
infrastructures pour pouvoir faire
progresser les sportifs qui sont des
arbres tout à fait tout à fait nous
avons un club qui comprend il ya
plusieurs bancs un matériel conséquent
on peut donc entraîner beaucoup de monde
et nous en avons qu'est ce que c'est
selon vous l'haltérophile
l'haltérophilie c'est un sport
que l'on dit de force mais il faut
surtout être plutôt dynamique il faut
être coordonnée et avoir disons
une
une bonne
contre activité musculaire et ensuite la
puissance s'acquiert par le travail en
musculation est ce que c'est un sport
qui est vraiment accessible à tous alors
le sport est accessible à tout le monde
y compris au fil garçons évidemment on
voit d'ailleurs depuis des années que
les filles ont pris ça à bras le corps
et elles sont même étonnés de voir les
charges qu'ils peuvent mettre à bout de
bras et en fait oui il est ouvert à tout
le monde et les meilleurs fille du coup
peuvent porter jusqu'à combien alors les
meilleures filles au niveau bac club a
bien sera de mon club un meilleur filles
c'est laurel elle pèse 64 kg lahrache 76
kg et à l'épaule et jette 87 aller
nationale et elle disputera la finale
des championnats de france en juin
prochain chez les garçons alors chez les
garçons nous avons
plusieurs personnes qui sont d'un niveau
un peu inférieur ils sont fédéral ou
inter régionale et puis nous avons aussi
des départementaux et des régionales
qu'est ce qui fait selon vous qu'un
sportif devient bonne haltérophiles
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il faut avoir surtout
une base ne contre activité musculaire
parce que le sport haltérophiles est
explosif c'est un peu comme si vous
voulez dans un départ 200 m donc il faut
donc une comptabilité musculaire
adéquate et puis après il faut être
souple et coordonnée à partir de là
c'est un sport à partir du moment où
vous avez cette disposition qui s'ouvre
à tout le monde quel que soit votre
poids de corps est ce qu'on les repère
rapidement passé sportif qui sont
susceptibles de devenir des bons
haltérophiles tout à fait on voit
rapidement une souplesse articulaire et
on voit rapidement une contre activité
musculaire absolument absolument ça va
très vite à décevoir garder on le voit
sur la coordination et les gestes le
voici ratera la seule chose qui
s'acquiert vraiment en haltérophilie
c'est la puissance ayant une force
vitesse mais cette force vitesse avait
acquises par des mouvements de tirage
d'un squat donc les performances ce
monde toujours avec une sécurité puisque
sans acquérir cette puissance vous
pouvez voir augmenter vos charges
l'envoyer c'est une discipline quand
même qu'ils qui stabilisent l'athlète au
départ et qui lui permet de monter au
front est-ce qu'on peut progresser
rapidement alors progresser rapidement
il ya donc deux mouvements et un
mouvement d'arracher et d'épauler jeter
le mouvement d'arracher est très
technique et il réclame une technique
parfaite puisque vous devez prendre la
barre du sol il a mené directement à
bout de bras à une prise de demain assez
large pour pouvoir se faire donc il faut
être précis il faut être technique mais
oui on arrive à progresser et
l'épaulé-jeté et plus en puissance quand
même puisque vous avez un temps d'épaulé
et un temps de jeter
c'est 2002 geste dans le même mouvement
mais oui on progresse
si je comprends bien si on a le geste on
peut vite progresser c'est à dire que
oui sans technique pouvait pas faire
d'haltérophilie et voulu surtout à
l'arraché même à l'épaule et le jeter ça
s'apprend donc séparément par des
tirages des squats et des goethe et
voilà on parle de semaines de mois
peut-être pour progresser deux semaines
et de mois
ça dépend ça dépend en fait de la
personne dépend des dispositions qui l'a
naturellement dernière question quel est
votre plus grand rêve à vous en tant que
coach ici bas mon plus grand rêve ce
serait de les amener en haut niveau
international
maintenant nous avons une nationale
allait pas loin de la classe
internationale j'entraîne ici depuis
deux ans c'est donc ma troisième saison
et peut-être que
elle pourrait peut-être faire une
carrière internationale
ce qui serait quand même très
intéressant mais même pour les autres il
évolue bien nous avons des filles de 59
kg qui commence déjà la petite l'avoir
mathilde la 59 kg elle arrache déjà 55
donc el harrach parce que ce n'est pas
de corps donc oui ce
sympathique
[Musique]
à mégoter maintenant deux athlètes du
club deux athlètes qui ont commencé
l'haltérophilie à quelques quelques
semaines quelques mois quelques années
alors lorraine et nicolas vous êtes
apparemment les deux meilleurs sportifs
du club est ce que c'est vrai
test on se débrouille bien on s'en sort
et pourquoi vous avez commencé du coup
l'haltérophilie donc moi j'ai découvert
l'haltérophilie par le crossfit et du
coup ben c'est via la pratique du
crossfit que j'ai
j'ai de plus en plus d'affinités avec
l'haltérophilie et donc du coup je me
suis dit pour améliorer ma technique est
améliorée mais perd ce de manière
générale en haltérophilie pont je
profite je vais m'inscrire dans une
salle d'haltérophilie alors nicolas pour
vous c'est un peu plus récent c'était il
ya seulement un an ouais en fait j'ai
commencé du coup l'haltéro là il ya un
an le crossfit depuis trois ans du coup
un peu comme un peu comme lauren par
rapport au cra suite le fait de
travailler plus la technique que la
l'intensité des mouvements je peux ça
plus intéressant est ce qui est
intéressant justement dans ce sport
qu'est ce qu'on travaille on travaille
différentes facettes de notre fitness on
travaille bien la force parce que là
l'haltérophilie c'est avant tout un
sport de force et on travaille aussi la
mobilité parce que si on n'est pas
mobile ben on va pas être bien placé
sous notre bar et du coup notre baron va
pas réussir à la remontée on travaille
aussi dans notre technique c'est mine de
rien l'arraché l'épaulé jeté son deux
mouvements qui sont très techniques
certes il faut être fort mais il faut
aussi assimilé le mouvement pour avoir
une position optimale à la fin et
réussir réussir notre barque et pourquoi
vous avez choisi ce club en particulier
ben moi c'était c'était là on va dire je
mets du crossfit ici donc du coup le
fait de devoir le coach
va entraîner les autres personnes ça m'a
donné envie de rester ici tout
simplement fait même chez aux lorraines
alors moi je fais pas le crossfit ici
mais je fais l'haltéro ici parce que bah
c'est l'association en fait la plus
proche je dirais pas là où j'habite donc
du coup ces niveaux localisation oui on
n'a pas beaucoup en ile de france même
dans les yvelines comment comment ça
s'explique c'est peut-être pas un sport
encore assez répandu encore un sport
assez démocratiser oui c'est ça commence
à venir petit à petit on voit de plus en
plus d'adhérents surtout plus en plus de
femmes aussi avant il y avait vraiment
très peu de femmes et là il y en a de
plus en plus grâce au crossfit et mais
ça manque encore de démocratisation un
peu partout en fait en france
et quand on vous avait dit à votre
entourage que vous faisiez
l'haltérophilie comment ils ont réagi à
moi c'est toujours les mêmes messages
l'attention attendent aux attentions
attendait mais sinon bah comme celui du
crossfit depuis trois ans ça les a pas
pas trop choquer mais plus le cost et
attention aux blessures que qu'autre
chose est-ce qu'on n'est pas encore dans
les clichés
ci encore encore si parce qu'en soit on
dit attention à ton dos mais d'un autre
côté l'haltérophilie c'est quand même un
sport où justement on renforce tout ce
qui est ceinture abdominale est
justement aussi le dos donc du coup les
haltérophiles c'est les personnes qui on
limite le dow le plus solide donc il ya
quand même enfin c'est assez je sais pas
comment dire c'est un cliché non fondées
on fait attention à notre dos il est
très résistant faut pas s'inquiéter des
questions et vos objectifs à tous les
deux dans cette discipline
nos objectifs moi personnellement mon
objectif c'est de
d'améliorer ma technique et d'encore
augmenter en en
en performance de soulever plus lourd
pour voir jusqu'où en fait mon corps est
capable d'aller pour le challenge est
toujours plus nicolas aubin mois début
c'était plus un loisir là je vais tester
la compétition la début avril voir où je
peux aller après j'ai pas de grandes
ambitions non plus mais le grand est et
ouest ont comparé aux autres un petit
peu le président disait qu'il fallait
remplir l'armoire à trophées est-ce que
woods vous allez la remplir on essaie on
travaille pour
on verra ça un petit message pour ceux
peut-être qui veulent découvrir ce sport
allez-y tenter franchement c'est top
c'est un sport très ludique est vraiment
très intéressant à pratiquer
moi je le conseille j'ai adhéré dès la
première séance nicolas rey puis en plus
ici les gens sont sympas et une bonne
ambiance tout le monde se poussent donc
tout le monde s'encourage donc tu as
kasserine
[Musique]
si vous voulez tester l'haltérophilie
ici à montigny le bretonneux ses 210
euros pour la compétition et 190 euros
pour le loisir venez tester
[Musique]